hier dans l'émission il ya un truc que
j'ai vraiment kiffé j'étais dans
l'incroyable talent la france a un
incroyable talent c'était au lavabo pour
ce qu'il avait manqué ça donnait ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est pourquoi
en cours
secours
de quoi là
tu ton gosse
c'est pourquoi
c'est ma vie
je suis coincé
on a emballé toute la soirée
cible
en deux mois je suis ton cadeau
un belle arnaque
non non
au mikado
tout chamallow
[Applaudissements]
les 81
je suis ton grand support la tâche du
propos la toile
je suis au la farce
ouais
[Musique]
iran
ça
brand c'est suffisant ni plastique jeté
ma magic situe mastic - qui capotent
semi papillotes genou mais pas chez
cette je suis ton chien saucisse à 4
packs qui suit en paix
couleur leur quartier
[Musique]
il est
il
non
je suis pour l'instant
m
[Musique]
bon allez
aulas
[Applaudissements]
tiens au lavabo je suis pas sa source
mais j'adore ce showman mais moi je te
jure t exceptionnel est vraiment bravo
mais qui veut une canette de coca suis
d'abord un truc c'est gratuit tu aimes
exceptionnelle assise canal à la demande
est franchement pour moi tu es
l'incroyable talent que cette année je
suis ton grand que si dame nature
c'est là que j'ai senti plein d'amour
dans six mois il hallucine alors été
haussée une valve ou c'est vraiment eu
sa c6 il est son métier c'est une vanne
qui devient sérieuse parce que c'est
devenu du travail et de réserver en fait
du coup l'udc ce qui je continue ce que
j'ai toujours aimé ça prend une ampleur
jamais on sera et on sait quoi bon bah
de soutenir à fond ouais merci ça je te
le dis vraiment on va tout mais à fond
joe qui pensent comme toi merci je kiffe
raymond